Speaker 1: So this is a story that is notable,
but it's notable for different reasons than
most of the people who are reacting to it
think it's notable for one of Donald Trump's
election fraud.
Lawyers Jenna Ellis quit the Republican Party
live on her television program yesterday.
She hosts a show called The Truth on Real
America's Voice.
I don't know what that is either, but that's
what it is.
That's what it's called.
And on that show yesterday, she said she's
out she's out of the Republican Party until
further notice.
But why is she out?
Because as far as she's concerned, the Republican
Party isn't crazy enough.
The Republican Party isn't fighting hard enough
to argue that Donald Trump actually won the
2020 election.
And so she's leaving now.
I'll explain more in a second.
But let's first look at the clip.
Speaker 4: All of them, including Ronna McDaniel,
should resign now until they do.
As of today, I am resigning from the party.
I am changing my voter registration.
And I'm no longer a Republican until the party
decides that it wants to be conservative again.
Even if I stand alone for the truth, I will
stand for the truth.
A compromised, corrupted majority is not a
majority worth being a part of.
If we genuinely want to create a more perfect
union, we have to stand up for our principles
against the corrupted machine of self-serving
politicians in Washington.
Speaker 1: So what is this all about?
Jenna Ellis is quitting because some emails
leaked where a top Republican National Committee
lawyer criticizes what Jenna Ellis was doing
vis a vis election fraud with Rudy Giuliani
and the whole lot of them in the November
election and in the months following it.
And Jenna doesn't like it.
Jenna's personally insulted.
There actually were some people in the Republican
Party who are still Republicans, and I don't
agree with them on policy.
But there were some Republicans in the Republican
Party that realized after the 20 20 election
that Joe Biden won, Donald Trump lost.
That's it.
And that when Jenna Ellis and Rudy Giuliani
and Sydney Powell were going around the country
holding these hearings, flying around the
country, passing covid among themselves, remember,
Jenna got it, Rudy got it, etc., Rudy got
it, et cetera, claiming these conspiracies
about there were massive dumps in the middle
of the night and there was a van with food
and all of this stuff.
There were some Republicans, including people
like Ronna McDaniel and others in the Republican
Party, who said, we look ridiculous.
We're becoming we're becoming an even bigger
laughing stock.
They would say it's just we're not looking
good.
They were already a laughing stock stock.
It was becoming a bigger one.
And Jenna Ellis is mad that not everybody
was on board with her election conspiracy
theories.
And so she's quitting the Republican Party
in protest.
This isn't a principled and moral Republican
saying the party has abandoned me.
I will no longer vote for Republicans.
I am going to the Democratic Party or I'm
moving to the left.
That's not what this is.
It's someone saying the party isn't nutty
enough.
I'm too nutty essentially for the Republican
Party.
And so I'm leaving.
And here she is in a painfully long winded
clip explaining more about why she's doing
this.
So, Jenna, why would you want to stay in the
Republican Party?
You doesn't sound like you have a home there.
And I heard I was just passed a note that
you might have an announcement to make regarding
your affiliation as a Republican.
Speaker 4: Yes.
Well, I also announced today that I am leaving
the Republican Party until the Republican
Party comes back home to conservatives.
I will stand up and champion truth, conservative
principles, our Declaration of Independence
as America's charter and the US Constitution.
But I will not stand and abide by a party
that says that we have to support everything
that comes under the banner of our even though
it's not conservative for running, for example,
to tweet in Affirmation of Pride Month for
this whole infrastructure bill, for what Mitch
McConnell said about President Trump in the
aftermath of the second impeachment hoax.
All of these things are not conserving our
principles of liberty and justice for all.
They're not conserving our Constitution.
So I'm not going to stand by and support a
party that doesn't support my values.
And if every single registered Republican
is a true conservative demands of the Republican
Party.
Speaker 1: OK, so at some point I have to
just cut it.
I mean, this went on for several more minutes.
Not not a concise explanation, but all that
stuff about the Constitution and all of what
she's saying, what she means is not everyone
at the Republican Party is on board with my
embarrassing and flaccid attempts to steal
the election.
And I'm mad that they thought what I was doing
didn't make any sense.
So the bigger story here is, is this going
to develop into a bigger schism or rift in
the Republican Party, which could damage them
in twenty, twenty two, which I would love?
It's too early to tell.
Remember that Jenna Ellis is in the pro Trump
side of the party, people like Ronna McDaniel,
I guess they're sort of like Trump agnostic.
I think McDaniel realizes if the party's voters
are with Trump, the leadership probably needs
to stick with Trump, too.
But she seems to realize Trump is sort of
a cartoon.
So when less is really clear that the voters
are abandoning Trump, I don't think this fracture
in the party is going to become serious.
And as you know, if you've been watching the
show for the last few weeks, Republican voters
are overwhelmingly with Donald Trump right
now.
Now, what would be interesting, this is sort
of a smaller question than will the party
completely cracken to.
What's an interesting question to consider
is whether there will be a real fight as to
whether the twenty, twenty two campaigns of
these Republicans up for reelection will be
run on twenty twenty was stolen by Democrats
and Joe Biden.
That's one way they could run in twenty, twenty
two.
They could run on policy.
Right.
Or they could run on you know, Democrats are
communists and Joe Biden's a Marxist.
And that's really, really bad.
My instinct is that Trump and the national
media figures are going to keep pushing.
The election was stolen and that's why we
need to win twenty, twenty two narrative.
But I think Republicans at the local level,
at least many of them are going to go with
not policy.
No, they're not going to go with.
Policy's done for this party, local Republicans,
or at least the Republicans that have to focus
on how they talk about the election in their
district with their constituents are going
to go with communism is bad.
And Democrats, you know, gas prices and Marxism
and spend, spend, spend, that type of thing,
they've totally abandoned policy.
And that would be an interesting thing to
see in 2022.
Do they run on the election was stolen or
do they run on?
We've got to stop this communism, which of
course, doesn't exist.
I think it will be the latter